[Applause]
the gods vanished
and left our world and chaos creating
altering destroying
the anthem is all that remains
you're just alone coming these walls can
protect us forever
something is out there it wants to
destroy us all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how cool was that tremor you guys have
seen it a couple times and it's so cool
every time I see it so I know all of you
like me have had tons of questions about
anthem since last year because we're all
by our fans so we're gonna do something
a little bit different for the rest of
the show and we're gonna take a deep
dive into anthem so I'm gonna bring out
some members of the bio team to chat
with us ladies and gentlemen please give
a warm welcome to Casey Hudson Marc Dara
and Kathleen roots are
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right thanks guys thanks for coming
out today
the show right yep it's gonna be very
exciting so Casey we're gonna go ahead
and just jump right in and get started
with you so now we know that you all
started or case you started your career
at Bioware
way back in the day but you took a
couple years off but before you came
back you actually worked on anthem
before you left yeah that's right so you
know first of all it's amazing to be
back it's awesome to be making games for
Bioware fans you know we have the best
fans so it's been super satisfying to
come back to it and you know I just want
to be able to continue the legacy of the
studio and that's kind of where it
started with anthem is just thinking
about you know what is the evolution of
a Bioware game and we wanted to create a
brand new world for people to discover
you know a whole new world of story and
character but we also wanted to do
something that was you know more of a
dynamic and living world in the game
that would change every time you came
back and played it we also wanted to do
something where you know if you want to
invite your friends into it then you
could do that as well so that was really
the initial vision of the game not an
MMO not a multiplayer game with story
sort of bolted on this side but
something new and different and I think
the team has really captured that vision
over the years your fans really love the
stories from Bioware but I think we're
kind of curious how you're planning to
make story work in this shared world so
a great story for Bioware is really
about characters that you can have a
connection with choices you get to make
and feeling like the stories about you
in a lot of multiplayer games those
things get diluted because you're mixing
multiplayer and storytelling into the
same areas now you can build a solution
to that but you have to really build it
into the core of the game and that's
what we've tried to do with with anthem
so what we call our world my story so
when you're out in the open world the
world is really dangerous
and you're focused on your mission and
this is where other players get to play
with you the thing that's really
interesting about this it's unique for
for anthem is that this is a living
shared war
so whether there's weather or it's
nighttime what we're experiencing we're
experienced together everyone that's
playing anthem in a Teta at a moment is
seeing the same thing and this is what
we mean when we talk about our world
it's a shared world that we all
experience together but then when I
finish my mission I come back to a base
like for Tarsus and this is a
single-player experience I turn in my my
rewards I talked to some characters I
experienced the choices of my action and
this is where your story really lives
and breeze and by doing it this way we
were able to combine that impact an
agency of a single player story with the
fun of teaming up with your friends to
play co-op in combat and we're also
designing it so that we can add story
for years to come so one of the first
things that we hear when from our
community is they want to continue to
play in our worlds when they finished
Mass Effect or Dragon Age players want
more story and so we've designed anthem
in a way that we can actually add more
story for years to come and it could be
anything a new moment with a character
that you've grown to love or event in
the world that deep into the lore or an
entirely new storyline and plot well I'm
certainly not gonna complain about more
story and I'll take anybody house there
is going to either so caffeine I wanted
to ask you from a writing perspective
since you are the lead writer can you
speak to what it's like to create a new
world like anthem from the beginning
well what's really exciting for us and
not just the writers but all of the the
devs the designers the artists is that
we're creating something new and
mysterious for players to discover so at
the heart of the premise of anthem is a
world left unfinished by the gods but
the gods left behind their massive tools
and those tools are in constant conflict
with this unknowable force called the
anthem of
creation and the chaos of those things
pushing against each other means that
the world is constantly being reshaped
in new and unpredictable ways yeah
violent storms mutant creatures gigantic
monsters it's a dangerous environment
that you need to wear a suit of power
armor a javelin - to be safe and now
something I think a lot of players out
there maybe don't stop to think about
it's just how much work goes into
creating a new intellectual property or
IP as we've been saying now you know
we've seen all these different creatures
and Mark you mentioned the storms what's
the process of creating a game like from
scratch yeah it's something we've done a
few times at Bioware you know and really
the hardest part is getting started just
kind of getting off the blank page so
what we tried to do is we think about
the new experiences that we're trying to
unlock for players so like what is the
fantasy fulfillment what are the new
things you actually get to go and do
that are different from what you've
played before so that's where we start
and then once we think about those
things you know that's the power of
creating new IP especially for games is
that you actually get to build a whole
fictional universe that's meant to bring
out a certain experience and then once
we do that then we kind of we still need
to build all the rest of the stuff and
what unlocks s creatively is to think
about like principles around art style
tone and even the technology and the
politics of our new world and then from
there we can actually go and build out
every last detail yeah and one of the
unique challenges for anthem is that
it's a world and experience that's meant
to feel alive like it's happening right
now and so the world is always changing
weather the storms seasons and yeah it's
a really great concept to write for
because what it means is it gives us the
opportunity to drop into the world
almost in real time a dramatic event
that changes the world for everyone and
that could be anything from game play to
lure the needs of all of the moving
parts in the dynamic world sound really
cool the way that they sound like
they're gonna come together but even
though there's obviously a lot going on
it really
back to your character so let's talk
about who we're gonna be playing as and
why we're fighting these crazy piece so
you are a freelancer uniquely skilled to
pilot these EXO jet these javelin
exosuits
and you need those suits to survive and
fight in this world because the world
will kill you but on top of that our
ancient rivals the Dominion have they
discovered a way they think to weaponize
the anthem of creation and so we need to
stop them and protect the free people of
tarsus no I call this power armor a
couple different things as is it a suit
is it a javelin like what's the what's
the cannon term here we call them
javelins and there are four and they
each have unique abilities there's the
Ranger and then there's the Colossus the
interceptor and finally the storm yeah
so each javelin gives you a different
way to play the game but the thing to
remember is like Kathleen said you're
not your suit you are freelance or a
pilot which means you can decide which
suits you want to use based on your mood
based on the mission you want to engage
it or these or the javelins that your
friends are using so really what this
allows us to do is we've built the suits
to look like they're built from the
materials of the world so they each have
their own unique abilities let's take a
look at the Ranger now the Ranger is a
more generalized suit able to do a lot
of different things but use really
designed for up close and personal
combat one-on-one for the most part the
Colossus is heavier more specialized but
able to really in big weapons that let
them data state the battlefield
I'm just gonna say the storm looks like
it's gonna be my favorite I'm sure you
guys know I started picking your face
right now - so the javelins look awesome
but we're gonna take a couple questions
right now so Casey tweeted some of you
may have seen asking for people out
there to send us your questions and the
first one is gonna be from out it's
sweet Nicole who asks as a player who is
all about making their character their
own what kind of customization options
will be available in anthem yeah so we
really want players to express himself
both through customizing the way their
their javelin plays through gear and
weapons but also being able to
personalize the way that it looks both
through paint jobs as well as changing
the actual geometry of the suit itself
we want teams to be able to do this as
well and because you're going to be
using a javelin for a long period of
time we really want you to be able to
make it your own
I'm glad you brought that up because
actually a Jayla Gator has a question
connected to customization monetization
how when loop box cosmetics yeah so we
are going to have some cosmetics and
vanity items that you'll be able to
purchase but you're always going to know
what you're gonna buy before you spend
any money on it so no loot boxes no
ability to pay for power so that means
no ability to spend money on game play
advantage at all within anthem but even
more important that we want to make sure
that anthem is an immersive experience
that feels like it's complete from the
get-go so that means the main story a
big open world and an ongoing service
that provides new content for a long
period of time new story new new new
experiences for everyone well I'm glad
to hear that I can make my javelin pink
that's really all I want to know I'm
gonna be honest all right Casey we
talked earlier about this being a co-op
experience so can you tell me a little
bit about how the team game plan anthem
is gonna work yeah it really is about
you know the fun of teaming up as as a
team of superheroes and working together
so you want to get a few people together
of different classes so you know I think
here we're gonna see the the Colossus
you know just hammering people on the
ground in gameplay we can have a look at
that so heavy artillery being really
strong you know in melee combat
and then here you've got the Ranger
shooting down from above and then
they're using calm and you know combos
and special abilities and stuff like
that but what I love is you don't just
run around you're swimming and flying as
well so it's interesting because at the
sleep Jones wants to know how will you
balance multiplayer with single-player
storytelling
so anthems really built around trying to
combine the the impact of having your
own personal story with the fun of
playing with other players but we really
want to make sure that that playing with
other people feels like a choice so for
people that want to just experience the
story we you're gonna be able to do that
now going out into an open world like
this by yourself is going to be a little
bit more challenging than the team of
four people and we've really tried to
balance the co-op experience to be fun
even for people that don't normally
engage in this kind of thing so I really
hope that everyone at least gives co-op
a try okay that's good to know if you
want a role solo you can but more
difficult well I know you all are on the
edges of your seats how about we show a
little gameplay yeah all right so I'm
Kevin you think you're gonna set this up
for us I will so the your you and your
friends have decided to play a mission
called scars and villainy the scars have
put together an acid-based super weapon
so you gotta take them out so you start
in the Strider which is like a giant
Walker and it's your forward base of
operations you have a conversation with
your crew
palek FEI and owen and you'll hear owen
he's going to talk us through the
mission as we as we experience it here
and yeah then you just get into your
javelins suit and you head out with your
friends all right well thank you so much
mark casey kathleen for talking to me
about anthem today we're gonna go ahead
and roll the gameplay now enjoy
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
freelancer times are good to work they
said these bastards made some kind of
acid and using it as a weapon
so fine or they're making this garbage
and shut it all down
[Music]
[Music]
owen what's the plan here picking up
loads of scars nearby take a look around
the area but sir be careful
[Music]
right checking out the Skycam Samar look
at all the women so I'm the other
turrets better move quickly
[Music]
there's a shaker on it wait something's
hard get it closer look with you see
those radiant pieces of energy there
echoes from the anthem of creation loads
of scars nearby be careful
return them to the relic you've got to
silence it fast
it's got silence disaster overseas do
you think we get a bonus for wait
something's happening
what the hell was that I think that was
whatever laid all the eggs around here
the sound came from below your position
on the plus side this definitely cancel
what hazard pay there's a trainer this
acid gunk leading down follow it we
should find the source
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys yep and that was that was
actually just a short version of the
full demo that we brought here to LA so
if you want to come by the Anthem
theater here at EA play and check out
the game lodge so I'm sure the question
on everyone's minds when do we get to
play so anthem comes out February 22nd
2019 on Xbox one Playstation 4 and PC
the mark your calendars everybody fire
after tweaks thank you so much again to
keep the entire Bioware team I know you
guys have that awesome theater outside
so I will see you guys there alright I
also want to give a big thank you to all
of the developers who showcase their
games today and everybody working hard
at their Studios back home around the
world let's give them all a round of
applause now some of what you saw today